في فرنسا بتزامن مع جلسه للبرلمان الفرنسي
بشان التصويت على مذكرتين لحجب الثقه عن
الحكومه بهدف اسقاطها بسبب قرارها تمرير
مشروع تعديل نظام التقاعد تستعد النقابات
لموجه جديده من الاضرابات في محاوله للضغط
على الحكومه للتراجع عن قانونها المثير
للجدل حيث يستعد مراقبه حركه الملاحه
الجويه للبدء في اضراب لينضموا الى
المسيرات احتجاجا على سن التقاعد
القانونيه من 62 الى اربعه وستين عاما
هيئه الطيران المدني دعت الى الغاء 30% من
الرحلات الجويه في مطار اورلي بالاضافه
الى 20% من الرحلات من مطار مدينه مرسيليا
الواقع جنوب فرنسا الرئيس الفرنسي ايميل
والماكرون اعرب عن امله بان يسلك مشروع
مساره الديمقراطي حتى النهايه في خطوه
اعتبرت تحديا لرفض القانون
وانضم الينا من باريس فادي الداهوك مراسل
العربيه ليطلعن على مزيد من التفاصيل فادي
بدايه الى اي مدى ربما هناك توقعات بان
تحدث هذه الجلسه للبرلمان الفرنسيه
ربما حسما او خرقا فيما يتعلق بحجب الثقه
عن الحكومه بعد حوالي نصف ساعه من الان
اهلا ابراهيم فعلا كما ذكرت هذه الجلسه
سوف تبدا بعد اقل من نصف ساعه تقريبا لكن
ليس لها حظوظ كبيره بان تتمكن من اسقاط
الحكومه لان مذكرتي حجم الثقه بحاجه الى
تصويت 287 نائبا اي الاغلبيه حتى تمر هذه
المذكرات حتى الان الامور ضبابيه هناك
تعويل على اصوات الجمهوريين الذين هم
منقسمين حقيقه فيما بينهم بين مؤيدين
لمشروع قانون رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما
ومعارضين له لكن الامور ما زالت في الشارع
ساخنه جدا هناك تظاهرات بدات تخرج في عدد
من المدن الفرنسيه وهنا في باريس ايضا
الان تخرج تظاهره في احد شوارع العاصمه
كما ان طلاب جامعه السربو اليوم او قبل
قليل قرروا البدء بتنفيذ اضراب وعصيان في
مبنى الجامعه الواقع في منطقه تولبياك صوت
نحو الف طالب من هؤلاء على ان يقوموا بهذا
العصيان والان الشرطه تطوق ذلك المبنى هنا
نحن امام مبنى البرلمان وكما ترون هناك
تاهب امني كبير جدا تحسبا لخروج تظاهرات
في هذه المنطقه ايضا لان هناك دعوات كثيره
تخرج على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي للتظاهر
واستمرار التحركات ضد مشروع هذا القانون
طبعا اليوم ان تمكن النواب من التصويت
لصالح مذكرتي او احدى مذكرتي حاجب الثقه
عن الحكومه على الحكومه رئيسه الوزراء
اليزابيث ان تقوم بتقديم استقالتها لكن
حتى الان الامور ليست واضحه تماما واذا لم
تنجح هاتين المذكرتين فان القانون سيصبح
نافذا ابتداء من اليوم ابراهيم لكن اذا
كان القانون نافذا النقابات اكدت انها
مستعده للتصعيد تصعيد الاضرابات
والاحتجاجات ايضا كيف يمكن عكس هذا الامر
اذا ما تم اقراره ولماذا تذهب بعيدا اذا
كان الامر سيحسم اليوم
النقبات تعول على حشد كبير وعلى حركه
اضراب تشل الاقتصاد الفرنسي لتشكل الضغط
على الحكومه وبالتالي اجبار الرئيس مكروه
على سحب هذا القانون وهذا الامر متوقع
ووارد بحسب كيف ستكون هذه الحشود يوم
الخميس المقبل في الثالث والعشرين من هذا
الشهر هو الموعد الذي حددته النقبات وايضا
الاحزاب اليساريه التي تدعمها لكي يكون
يوما للاضراب والتظاهر بالاضافه الى
التظاهرات التي تخرج من قبل الطلاب وهذه
التظاهرات هي ربما التي تشكل فرقا هذه
الايام لانها تخرج من دون تنسيق هؤلاء ليس
لهم قائد وبالتالي هم
محررين من الاحزاب ومن النقبات يقومون
بتحركاتهم وحدهم ويشتبكون للتفاوض معهم
جديد للحكومه الفرنسيه انا اشكرك حتى
الساعه على كل هذه المعلومات مراسله
العربيه كنت معنا مباشره من باريس